first of all what's it been like you two
working on set together because just
listening to you in the few seconds you
guys seem like you're best friends i
love her
i love her i love her
how are you guys trouble
there's good trouble and bad trouble
right most of the time in big trouble
every once in a while we're bad trouble
i love that so much
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
the truth i am really bad at wearing my
mask
okay
it happens to the best of us i truly am
i'm the youngest of three girls and i'm
a bit of a like i don't like following
rules
right
yeah georgia
is really good at wearing masks well
yeah
that rule what so she keeps you in line
yeah he's really good at that one she's
really good at that one so she's always
got it on and i'm just like i'm
walking around with the face shield
that's down wearing it like a necklace
and i see george said i'm like damn it
right she keeps you in line that's good
without even saying a word
yeah um paula is so exciting uh you know
having you on this series maxine she's
the boss what do you love about her i
love my i like maxine because maxine is
she's measured
maxine is fun
maxine is not to be effed with
he's not
and maxine really cares
yeah she really really truly cares
i love that uh george was like for you
coming back to this series come back to
this character was that always the plan
no not at all no i think when when billy
and i got on that boat back in 2015 and
sailed off in the sunset i think we
really thought that was it that was the
end of the book you know
and um
and i didn't really think much about it
after that i was there was a part of
anything it was just ted i was so glad
that sarah ended up safe and happy with
the man
that was nice yeah there was a lot of
years where that maybe that wasn't
necessarily going to happen and uh
so then
uh bruckheimer television approached
billy and i about doing a 20th
anniversary limited series and that
sounded really interesting i mean i
didn't really want to take them out of
paradise but um
if there were people that that really
were interested in the story then it was
like well of course you know what that
would be amazing
and uh the 20th anniversary came and
went obviously because covet and story
evolved a little bit and and and i'm
glad that it did evolve you know because
we get paula newsom and we get vandy
people then we get matt laurie and we
get mel rodriguez and
um
and it's a dazzling now it's a new thing
now it's a dazzling new place that's so
exciting i was going to say yeah what
brings them back they seem like they
were living the life you know they were
right and now they're back in it
well sarah gets a call from an old
friend that the old friend's in trouble
and and she just thinks she's just gonna
roll into vegas for a couple of days and
take care of stuff and be on her way
i love that long weekend
for a long weekend yeah
not possible
um
you know
obviously you guys have talked about
this before but when you're on a show
and you're dealing with such dark
storylines you're just talking to
mandeep and she said she likes to break
out beyonce after the scenes rap just to
get her head clear what do you guys do
hmm
what do i do i quite honestly i spent a
lot of time with my friends
yeah you know i go up to lake arrowhead
with my niece you know
i make sure and just have to make sure
my legs my feet are firmly grounded in
the reality that is paula's life
you know
i get that georgia what about you i mean
you've been doing this for so long now
oh well thanks and you know and it does
it is weirdly haunting you know even if
the stories aren't real
and for many years they were you know
they were really literally most of this
the early stories on the show were
pulled out of headlines and stuff and
that that gave it like a gravitas that
was
um
sometimes really tough to process you
know because
and now it's easier because it is
make-believe but i'm with mandeep i
think you know
number one i dance you know that's
always helps
and i'm also with paula like yeah
calling a friend is is always a great
thing too
and um and i love romantic comedies and
disney movies
i've definitely watched a few of those
after a long day of work
absolutely puts you in that feel-good
space again right then you're like all
right we can do this again tomorrow yep
petting my dogs
that's
yeah
uh georgia what was it like for you
working with william peterson again i
mean did you guys did it feel like any
time it passed
uh
you know i think
for for a minute i thought it was gonna
feel like that was like wow it's been
five years and we've stayed in touch but
it's not that you know it's not the same
as when you're working with someone
every day like when you're on set
and um
but i and and we started
zooming that was the first thing that we
did obviously because it covers we
started having these zooms and that was
really surreal
yeah um probably the most surreal it
still is kind of zooming philly it's so
weird
it's like just never did that before
and um
and then immediately wow when when uh
the first day we worked together it was
incredibly comforting
and just this best feeling you know i
i've never gotten to reprise a role i
think that's pretty rare in general and
then they get to do it with a friend
that you've known for 21 years to take a
journey like that with them is
immeasurably special and yeah fun and i
think we're kind of annoying sometimes
because we have lots of inside jokes and
we'd roll our eyes at the same time and
and i think other people would be like
will you guys stop it you're like an old
weird married couple
paula were they annoying not at all
you know quite honestly what i was like
i want in
like what the hell
but i could tell that they have just
such a remember the first i'm going to
tell you this the first day that billy
came on set you remember georgia
georgia changed
georgia changed and i was like
no
i totally would because she changed
because now she's like she's like
connected to him in this
really
it's it's i can't even put words on it
you know what i mean
and they have so much on that's 20 how
many years like 20 years 21 i think yeah
wow
that's longer than some marriages well i
was going to say that's my relationship
is a make-believe television
relationship
but it's also an honor to get to do that
how cool you know i think that that that
long-term relationship people who make
it work for 20 years and especially if
they actually seem to still really care
about each other yeah that is that's one
of the coolest things in the world to me
and so to get to explore that and play
that has been really exciting and
watching the shorthand and watching the
shorthand is just
it's beautiful see it's weird it's
annoying sometimes no no
paula said beautiful not annoying
well speaking of sarah grissom you know
what can we expect from their
relationship are we still gonna feel the
love
well i i so hope so i hope the audience
enjoys this the biggest risk i think
that the show's taking in some ways is
by
putting us together
um
you know we had
this 21
year long
sort of on-again off-again relationship
love affair you know they were together
they weren't together they were married
they were divorced they were running
away from each other
and
you know the episode one is going to
find them together and it's really the
first time that billy and i have played
that relationship on screen you know for
any length of time
so as i said it was an absolute ball for
me i really really enjoyed it i hope the
audience enjoys it too
that's so exciting um paula obviously
there's such a huge fan base with the
original series what are you excited for
them to see with this with csi vegas i'm
i'm excited
you know
i have a lot of respect for this show
the franchise
and i'm just excited for people to open
their hearts and their minds to seeing
more of america
you know
wednesday nights at 10 a.m
um 10 p.m excuse me um
because i i when i see it i'm in i'm in
awe and i'm impressed and i'm grateful
to be part of this group
yeah i can only imagine that's so cool
i'm so pumped for everyone to see this
georgia when you hear the theme song and
it's back is it like embedded in your
head because i get excited when i hear
that
oh thank you yeah i mean the who you
know wow they're pretty cool bands
pretty amazing fan uh
to say i'm a fan would be under
understanding how much i i love them did
you meet them did you meet them
we did i have a number of times one um
very old csi fans will remember that
roger daltrey actually had a guest
starring role on an episode of csi wow
and he was with us for maybe a week four
or five it was a sizable role and um so
yes i i did spend time with roger dalton
on a set
um
and i've seen the who play numerous
times and um and they've always been
really kind to the show and kind to
those of us that have gone to see them
i got a photo actually at um coachella
oh uh just a couple it was desert trips
just a couple of years ago that we
played with a number of bands for three
days and it was like paul mccartney and
the rolling stones and uh it's eric's
amanda and david berman and i
backstage
at the who
um and a photo with daltrey again so i
have that yeah they're awesome um and
there's also a newer rendition of the
song joy
ola
she's gonna kill me for not being able
to pronounce her name
and that song talk about i feel like her
covering the who who are you
in many ways it is it's actually the
soul of csi vegas
where csi crime scene is left off this
is now this is the present this is
what's happening this is the new
i really do think the audience is going
to fall in love with these characters
that uh jason tracy is so lovingly
created they are really cool dynamic
electric people and you're going to want
to take a journey that you've taken
already with them specifically that's so
cool i just got the wrap paulie you know
i got to ask you about being part of
marvel family spiderman no way home i
know you can't say much
but was the experience awesome i got to
tell you it was freaking amazing
it was friggin amazing because i'm
but i will tell you i'll just tell you
one thing i needed a stunt double
i got you working
that's all i'm gonna say i needed a
stunt couple
that is so cool guys thank you so much
also some wings
oh
i am getting all the tea right now
that's so cool thank you
congratulations morgan's been a pleasure
thank you